on va donner beaucoup d'ambiance on va
pousser les lions on va galvaniser les
lions aura vraiment gagner
[Musique]
première pierre de marée de tout l'été
la grève depuis
trois ans parce que
la peau depuis à
ces les graines moritz a bataillé sur la
marche balle et il obtient pas les
prolongations on va dire si la marche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on souhaite que tous les domaines et
même plainte qui porte l équipe
nationale du sénégal où les pousser à la
victoire pourtant gagne la première fois
le sac postal du trans tous des
d'année
[Musique]
je fais partie des gens qui portent
la peinture sur le corps laissé de
lettre du sénégal tous ces gens que vous
voyez à l'indicé de lettres sont venus
des régions de faire ça veut dire le
sénégal en miniature on va préparer tout
le temps avoir la coup d'avoir tout
pousse partout au stade pousser les
lions vers la victoire c'est la tenue
comme j'y vois asei c'est la tenue du
mas cops avec mon parcours c'est bien
vrai que c'est le garrec samedi c'est
légal seulement
son souhait c'était de gagner la coupe
d'afrique est
vraiment là notre mission aussi c'est
vraiment gagner la can et l'amener le
trophée jusqu'à là où il se repose
c'est grenoble
[Musique]